en 1947 la ONU resolvió la partición de
Palestina para crear un estado judío y
otro árabe pero 75 años después la idea
de un estado palestino no podría estar
más lejos algunos de los motivos los dio
a Antonio Gutiérrez en su mensaje por el
día internacional de solidaridad con el
pueblo palestino el secretario general
de la ONU dijo que la esperanza de una
paz se ve imposibilitada por la
ocupación israelí la expansión de los
asentamientos ilegales las demoliciones
y desalojos de poblaciones palestinas
así como el bloqueo en gaza y las
muertes de civiles palestinos en
cisjordania Aunque la visión de la
solución de dos estados en la que se
apoya la ONU se ha convertido en una
invocación manida sin objetivos claros
esta enumeración de Gutiérrez es la
violencia diaria en el terreno hoy por
ejemplo tres jóvenes palestinos dos de
ellos eran hermanos murieron cerca de
ramala y hebrón por fuego del ejército
israelí en un año que se ha convertido
en el más mortífero desde 2006 y en el
que el gobierno israelí No a formarse no
augura que esto vaya a cambiar las
negociaciones entre Benjamín netan Yahoo
y sus aliados están derivando en que
políticos israelíes de extrema derecha y
antiárabes tengan mayor poder de
decisión sobre los territorios
palestinos ocupados algo que grupos de
Derechos Humanos como pishnaw temen que
derive en una eventual anexión total en
paralelo a esto el Primer Ministro
israelí saliente y aíslapit instó a 50
países a votar en contra de que la ONU
pida la Corte Internacional de Justicia
una opinión sobre los efectos de la
ocupación y las acciones de Israel que
rige Y controla por completo la vida de
los palestinos